there aren't very many old buildings and
Panama City anymore economic growth has
led to a nationwide property boom when
Franklin Morales drives to the city he
surprised at how many new buildings he
sees the skyline changes almost monthly
Panama is now on of Latin America's
fastest growing countries Franklin
Morales is 28 years old he attended
University and gained experience working
abroad he's now using it back home in
Panama but not to earn big money
realmente otra cara el pais que la el
pais que continúa in porous a country as
another side ongoing poverty people who
lack access to healthcare and education
there are still fundamental problems
human dignity and adequate nutrition so
we think there's room for improvement
and a need for action and the way young
people must take over responsibility
after all we make up the majority of the
population nearly 40-percent of
Panamanians are under the age of 25 most
educated in outdated and overburdened
schools and universities here the
emphasis is on discipline rather than
encouraging students to think for
themselves
Franklin Morales and his friends refuse
to accept that in their free time they
organize regular workshops in schools
como se sentir Oh Alvin para conversar
ahora sobre lack TV anterior tambien
everything is worked out together and
nothing is compulsory the pupils learn
soft skills taking responsibility
working in teams and making decisions
for many of them that's completely new
career moccasin and I'm intaglio separa
pointing these a valuable tools
teenagers can acquire at 14 or 15 when
many are deciding what to do with their
lives we want to help them as early as
possible to plan their careers and
studies carrera SI cuando están en lo
que no piranhas her little daughter the
prospects for young people are not rosy
despite Panama's economic growth
Franklin Morales and his fellow
campaigners want to change that they're
still plenty to do in the health sector
as well
people who can't afford patient
contributions have a problem in Panama
City's largest hospital blood is in
short supply surgery is only scheduled
for patients who've donated their own
blood in advance in rural areas the
situation is even worse
sometimes doctors are at their wit's end
because there's not enough blood to
treat patients
twenty-eight-year-old garber a rebel own
asked himself what could be done he's a
friend of Franklin Morales and a doctor
he too felt something had to change on
this particular day he's off work after
finishing a night shift but he always
looks in that the blood bank to see
what's needed one lunacy you not see
longer a man of my twin brother and I
were born prematurely and we needed
blood transfusions in the pediatric
hospital although there were people who
helped us and donated blood it was hard
for my parents back then many years
later when I went to university to study
medicine I noticed the situation was
still the same that was when I decided
to found sangria Panama generics
adamantly well die Africa demo's unio
hitter a tocar sangrah bahama revenant
organization is called blood for panama
he visits companies talks with employees
and tries to persuade them to donate
blood regularly he spent a lot of time
campaigning for donations on top of his
work as a doctor and he's glad of every
person he's managed to convince it's
good to get support for his volunteer
work from kindred spirits though so he
and other volunteers have joined the
global shapers network they're connected
worldwide were thousands of other young
people committed to similar causes they
give each other advice and mutual
support in Hanuma and elsewhere in the
world